Hello slush. Good to be
here. How's everybody doing?
My name is Saraj revolver and hello world.
That's my intro on youtube where I
inspire and educate lots of developers to
build AI.
Today my talk is going to be about
decentralize artificial intelligence,
Aka what happens when we take the
two hottest technologies of today,
AI and blockchain and put them together,
right?
It's just sprinkle everything
on top of each other. Right?
So let's get right on into this. We've got
a lot to cover. So machine learning, AI,
this has been around since the 50s
it's not a new technology, it's,
it's a pretty old technology.
But basically the idea
has always been the same.
We have some data sets, right? Some input
Dataset, and we have some objective.
We have something that we want
the Ai to do. In this case,
classify a car.
Is it a car or is it not a car?
So what we do is we feed this
AI a bunch of images of cars.
So think of it like an excel spreadsheet
with two columns and column one you
just have pictures of cars. And column
two you just have labels. Karch,
our cargo hook, cocoa car, right?
And so the idea is that
the AI learns the mapping,
the relationship between the
input data and the output labels.
There is some relationship
between everything.
There is a function in life
for everything, but that's,
that's a bit of a tangent.
The idea though is that the human would
have to extract all the features of what
it means to be a car, right? This
is kind of what a car looks like.
This is the shape of the car,
this is what the exhaust pipe looks like.
And this was a very tiring process,
but this is what humans had to do.
We extract features by hand and so what
happened is once we've extracted those
features,
we would feed it to some kind of machine
learning model and there's a lot out
there.
Eventually it would learn the mapping
and then give it a new car picture and it
would know, hey, this is a car. But a few
years ago there was a scientist who said,
let me take one specific machine learning
model called a neural network and tre,
drop the beat, right?
Drop the mic and feed it.
Lots of data and lots of computing power
and add a lot of layers. Deep Layers,
Aka deep learning. That's what we call
it. What happened is when we did this,
it started outperforming every
other machine learning model.
And now deep learning is the
hottest topic in machine learning.
It is outperforming everything else.
Self driving cars, drug discovery,
everything hot that you're hearing about.
Hey, AI is coming from deep learning.
Okay,
so that was my one slide overview of AI.
So now blockchain,
right?
So a couple of years ago there
was a programmer who no one knows,
named Satoshi Nakamoto, who released
a paper on cryptography mailing list,
the killing US system called bitcoin.
That allows two people to transmit value
online without needing a third party,
namely a bank. So what happens is
instead of a bank being the third party,
there are a group of people called
miners and anybody can become a minor.
You just need a laptop, right?
Anybody can become a miner.
And the idea is that when I
transmit value to you from me,
these miners have to approve this
transaction there to say, okay,
let me check this list of transactions.
So every miner has a copy
of every transaction that
has occurred in the network
and they have to approve whether or not
this transaction is valid or not, right?
Cause they have the list. So you
might be thinking, wait a second,
couldn't someone just fake, just create a
bunch of accounts and say, Hey, I'm the,
I'm the majority of the minors.
Cause the majority of the miners have
to approve a transaction for it to be
added to this list of transactions.
Well know because the Toshi,
she said every single
minor has to prove that,
that they have solved some
random mathematical problem.
It's called the proof of work algorithm.
And that means that you have to have
more computing power and the 500 fastest
supercomputers in the world combined to
have the majority of the computing power
in the bitcoin network. And because
no one has that much computing power,
no one's been able to hack bitcoin.
And that's why it has a over 100
billion market cap as of yesterday,
more than the GDP of some countries
and no one's been able to hack it.
It's been around for a decade.
So really powerful technology.
Let's keep going here.
But the really,
really interesting part about bitcoin
is not the actual application but the
underlying data structure of bitcoin.
So this is kind of a rough diagram of
what it looks like. Very simplified.
But the idea is that we have
some list of transactions, right?
I'm talking about this list
of transactions that all
of the miners are holding
and we grew up these transactions
together into little groups that we call
blocks and each block points to the
next block. So one block is like, okay,
I'm Melissa transactions, here's the next
block. And that's why I was like, oh,
thanks for that. Okay, here's an
listen on the next block, right?
And it becomes this kind of chain
of blocks. Okay, blockchain, right?
So at the blockchain,
that's what we call this data structure.
And because of the proof of work
algorithm, no one can modify it.
It's an unalterable immutable
and computer science terms.
Shout out to all the
programmers out there.
It's an immutable data
structure that no one owns.
And this saved very powerful idea.
So I like to call this the Yin and
the Yang of Ai and blockchain, right?
These two technologies
go really well together,
but no one's really put them together yet.
So this is a very futuristic thing.
So the Yin is AI.
Ai Is probabilistic.
It's all about computing the
likelihood that something will happen,
the prediction of the future using what
it's learned. And Ai is always changing.
It's updating it's weights,
it's learning about the future.
And an AI is a set of algorithms that
guests at reality, the Yang part,
our blockchains, blockchains are not
probabilistic. They are deterministic.
You know exactly what's going to
happen, right? They are permanent,
they are unchangeable and they are
algorithms and cryptography to record
reality.
So these two things can go really well
together if you break them down into what
they're really good at.
So we live in a world where we are
all using these services, right?
And these services collect and monetize
our data. That's the business model.
But this is a problem because our data
is the most valuable thing we have and it
will become more valuable as
everything is slowly automated.
Your data will be the
only agency that you have.
It will be your most valuable asset,
so you need to own it.
But right now we're giving it away
for free in return for a free service.
Ideally, these services would be
paying us for our data, right?
But that's just not the case right now.
We need to Redo all of these apps that
we have in web 2.0 everything from Ebay
to Uber, to Lyft, all of it.
Facebook, right? Morally speaking,
this is a terrible idea til let
some humans control our data.
In the case of Facebook,
they modified the newsfeed to affect
large swaths of the populace and the 2016
political elections, for example, in the
u s it's just, it's just very corrupt.
It's just not a good system and not
even talking about it. Morally speaking,
let's talk about it. Technically speaking,
centralized systems are not good.
Take the case of a self
driving car network.
Let's say we've got three self
driving cars at an intersection. Okay.
Three of them at an intersection and
there to kind of decide who has the right
of way.
But if there was one central server that
they all had to talk to a million miles
or kilometers away, then it would
take forever. And there would be,
there would probably be an accident.
Ideally these cars could talk to each
other without needing a third party or a
central service or a server.
So both technically speaking
and morally speaking,
creating what are called decentralized
applications is a really good idea.
And it's what we call as developers web
3.0 and that's what's happening now.
If you're looking for something to
disrupt, you take blockchain, you take AI,
you combine it together,
and you create apps that have
never before been possible.
And that's the most exciting thing these
days. So this leads us to this idea.
It's a very abstract idea,
but it's starting to happen of what
are called decentralized autonomous
organizations or dowels for short.
You can also call them
dapps decentralized apps,
but the idea is that these are apps that
are run and maintained by the community
that uses them, right? So
think of Uber for example.
When I am a writer and I'm trying to find
a driver, I have to use a third party,
namely Uber to find that driver.
And so Uber takes a cut of this and
they have a bunch of malpractice as well
that we all know of through
all of their scandals.
But ideally I wouldn't have to trust Uber.
I could just find my driver.
He would get paid more. I would have to
pay less because there's no third party.
So it'd be better for both of us,
right?
We would all earn some equity because
we are all a part of the network.
It's not just about earning money.
We'd also earn equity and we would be
able to decide on the features of the APP.
So it would be a more democratic
process, right? It's, it's,
it's kind of like a community
owned grocery store, for example.
Instead of one century
central person owning it,
everybody who is a part of the network
would also be a participant in the
infrastructure of that network as well.
So there's a lot of good
that can come from this.
There's a lot of good that can come
from this and that's what we're going to
start to see as we move towards web 3.0
if you're looking for a really hot idea,
something really cool to do this is it.
Blockchain AI combined them together,
use this immutable ledger and
have an AI live on the blockchain,
or at least speak to the blockchain
and data is being pointed to.
There's some distributed hash table or
some kind of centralized storage stores.
And then there's a whole,
there's a whole token model.
We've only got two and a half minutes,
so I can't explain everything here,
but there's, there's so much,
there's so much. That's it.
That's what I'm trying to say. But
it's not all good. There's also bad.
I can't talk about the good
without talking about the
bad. Right. So imagine this,
what you're seeing here is a picture of
art that was completely generated by AI.
There is no human in the loop.
So imagine an AI that lives
on a blockchain and its job
is to just generate art.
So what it does, it does
this, it generates some art,
it then sells it on some marketplace.
It earns some money.
It uses that money to feed
itself more computing power.
It used that computing power to
then to then generate more art.
It just keeps amassing wealth and no one
can shut it down because it lives on a
blockchain, right? No
one can shut it down.
You'd have to have more computing power
than the 500 fastest supercomputers in
the world combined to shut it down.
Eventually it becomes the wealthiest
entity on the planet, right?
So that's kind of scary if you think about
it. It's an [inaudible], killable AI,
and it lives on a blockchain.
So how do we stop this?
It's our responsibility as developers,
as people,
people who don't even program to educate
ourselves on how this intelligence
works and only then will be, will be be
able to stop any kind of malpractice,
any kind of bad scenario,
right.
The will of the collective will
override any one bad actor.
So we have to educate ourselves,
be more aware. One resource for,
this is my youtube channel,
but the Internet is your university
so it's your responsibility to use it.
I stopped you. I'm going to end this
talk with a rap about decentralize AI.
So I want everybody to stand up
cause I know you guys are sleeping.
I know there's been some sleepy speakers
so please stand up everybody. All right,
everybody stand up. It's a, it's a wrap.
It's called smarter. It's a play on words.
It's,
it's a parody of Kanya west stronger.
So I want you to put your hands up in
the air as well. So, but let's just go,
let's go.
I got to read papers to
try and make me smarter.
I train my models in the cloud now
cause mile laptop takes longer.
I'll parse through day to like a boss.
Now, back then my code was wrong.
Wronger subscribe if you want to learn.
Now let's spread this AI power.
Let's pray to right now.
Let's train it right.
Let's make bucks tonight and make music
like Mozart tonight and pain our work on
a cross tonight. I've waited
for this software hall, my life.
Just give it some data and
watch it explore step back,
clap and keep an encore.
He trained on 40 cores. It's race or
make GP use anymore. I came bought,
started off aimless,
but now it's like God in the Matrix.
My Chat Bot speaks once I train it.
How it works with damn hard to make this.
It'll generate words that it predicts
and ally said, submit and tested.
This death is the shit to invest in new
data. Where's her trained it then tested.
Come in.
I got to read papers to
try and make me smarter.
How train mom models in the cloud now,
because my laptop takes longer.
I parse through data like a
bus. Now back then, Marcos,
what's wronger subscribe if you want
to learn now, let's spread this.
All right, everybody, thanks so much.
Please subscribe for more programming
videos and for now I've got to go assign
some credit,
so thanks for watching.